bill I believe your idea about acting is
not just talent and creativity and
imagination but it's also this business
side this very left brain type of
thinking about marketing and spending
time with computer and selling yourself
and being your brand as you've moved up
the ranks as you've been here for years
and booked more roles and become more
noticeable do you see that other people
in that stratosphere also think the same
and the ones that maybe you might have
climbed past didn't think that way well
I don't think of my I don't think of
climb past anybody they're probably
right on my butt right now and I just
don't know it but I'm but the answer is
yes the the when you deal with actors
who have been here longer than I have
and have been more successful than I
have the very very business minded and
very marketing minded and very strategic
minded I don't think that would have
lasted especially not at my age you know
when I when I look at actors who are my
age and who most of them have either
quit or they've made it really big and
so the people that I know are in my age
range who've made it really big have
done it by being absolutely strategic
when it comes to marketing I think it's
important I've done some marketing
seminars where I've spoken to actors and
said this is what you need to do and
then I've had some of them afterwards
contact me and say well can I pay you to
do it no I mean it it's a full-time job
and you have to do it from your passion
nobody can do this for you but it's the
thing actors don't like to do paperwork
and you know generally we don't like
that side of things but it's essential
if you were to break down your day or
your week how much time your waking
hours are spent on the business side the
being at the computer and how much is
spent on the creative thinking of a
great character back studying and for
cursing lines and hey can we need to go
over the scene 12 hours in one hour and
the one hour is a stretch I've got to
shoot tomorrow so when I get done with
you guys I'm gonna walk around Hollywood
look at my lines and feel them and
struggle with them and think oh my god I
can't do this then I'll walk up to
Griffith Park and I'll pray and I'll
think I can't do this and then I'll
decide that I can do it then it's done
I'm ready to go to set but I spent the
entire week before talking to you guys
marketing and submitting and stroking
relationships and looking for projects
and reading scripts so yeah a lot of its
business reading scripts is hard when
people start sending you scripts you get
five scripts in a week it's wonderful to
be set scripts but it takes two hours to
read each one if you're actually gonna
read it and not cheat and just say oh my
role is Bob I'm just gonna look for all
the instances of Bob in the script
so yes the marketing the business that's
99.9 percent of the time you mentioned
you walking around Hollywood reciting
your lines yeah youngmee on the other
day we were so fascinated by this guy
was in his own world rehearsing is that
something that you do is that I found it
fascinating yeah because people think
you're crazy and it helps this sense of
isolation that you have to have as an
actor you have to be completely in your
character and I do this you know I walk
to the gym walk back and forth with my
lines my little sides and my heads I'm
talking to myself out loud and people
stare and pull their children away and
you know it's okay that's what an actor
does I find that the best way for me to
to learn lines and to get the meaning of
the lines is to move while I'm doing it
I can't do while I'm sitting down so
it's good to walk and be in motion and
try to figure out these lines and the
words will tell you how they want to be
said if you walk with them enough like
you might think you have a line reading
but just keep working to keep working to
keep walking keep moving keep moving and
the words will tell you know this is how
I want to be said and and then you'll
have your reading that you can take to
set and have something else in your
pocket if you act want something
different
iterate when she said that's like a one
hour possibly portion of your day or any
others 12 oh yeah if that you know if
that because it it doesn't to sit around
thinking about how I might play a
character that I haven't booked it's of
no benefit I need to be spending this
time booking the character then I can
start working on the character it's not
a good business for dreamers I guess
unless you're extremely young extremely
beautiful and you have kind of a backup
of money then you could sit around and
dream but I can't I don't have time to
dream I don't have time to sit around
with other actors and have coffee and I
don't have time for any of that this is
so hard
I don't mean to some petty in that way
but you have to be completely focused on
what you're doing
what about to do a lot of scene study in
films sit around all day and watch
movies that you love and talk about how
Nicholson played it like this and it was
amazing and look how he got angry right
here and what about that I cannot bring
myself when I'm in my apartment to ever
watch a movie because I always think
there's something else I could be doing
what else could I be doing to further my
career instead of looking at Jack
Nicholson's career but I will go to
movies a couple times a week the
Egyptian runs a lot of older films and
have really enjoyed that I've enjoyed
studying these older actors who are in
my sort of type like Lee Marvin and
watching Edward G Robinson and watching
how these old guys worked the camera
even though the acting styles are
different there's a lot to be learned so
I'll go to school there you know about
once a week but sitting around watching
movies in the apartment I can't do it
because I'm always looking at the
computer and thinking is there one more
thing I could do before I go to bed
tonight there's that one more thing I
could do that might advance my career I
am caught I'm obsessed listening to
myself talk I want to quit this business
I'm too obsessed but I don't know how to
do anything else for a living this is
all I know how to do and all I wanted
you it's kind of sad isn't it
you